each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available I want to say how much I
admire your the fortitude of all of you
uh sitting through all of this enormous
uh Title Wave of wisdom that that you're
hearing here so
um let me pick up where we left off
remember I was talking about how to
build highly concurrent objects and I
spent the first part of the lecture
convincing you that linearizability is
almost always the correctness property
that you want uh there are certainly
times when you might want to deviate uh
from this and if I have time I'll give
you some examples of uh non linearizable
data structures that are still very
interesting but but for now I'm going to
stick with the main uh strategy so we
talked about uh
five um patterns for writing uh highly
concurrent data structures uh we covered
three of them I'm going to give you a
very quick review of the three
gray uh strategies uh just so that you
remember what they are and then we'll
push ahead uh I'll talk about the other
two ways of doing business then we'll
turn our attention from a very simple
data structure like link lists and look
at stacks and cues and counters and
other non-trivial uh data structures
applying the same kinds of approaches to
to
those so remember the um well the
simplest way is course grain
synchronization where you put a big one
lock on everything um that obviously
doesn't scale the next approach is fine
grain synchronization where we split an
object into multiple components and we
put a lock on each
component and the the basic idea is that
you only lock the parts of the object
that you need and as we saw this is much
easier to say than to do correctly any
subtleties uh any subtle difficulties
happen if you aren't very
careful now I should mention that um
even though the algorithms that I've
shown here have proofs that is they have
uh things called proofs and things
called theorems uh there's been very
little work on for example uh automatic
uh proofs or machine checkable proofs in
this area and this is an area that is
crying out for this sort of thing
because the data structures are either
finite or almost finite and there's a
history of papers that have been
published that have bugs in them so if
you're if you're looking for you know a
research area then uh proving that some
of these things actually work is uh I
think would be a very interesting U
thing to
do um the next thing is optimistic
synchronization where you search without
locking and if you find it you lock and
check that what you found uh was uh what
you saw really is what you
found uh if everything is okay then
you're done and you found what you were
looking for uh much faster than you
would have had you been uh what was the
phrase
acquiescent and otherwise uh you suffer
the penalty of having to do uh
everything over
again and so um usually this is cheaper
than locking but in if there's High
contention or if checking is too
expensive then uh this isn't a a great
idea uh the next thing that uh we will
we didn't do last time but we'll do this
time is what we call Lazy
synchronization and lazy synchronization
is based Bas on the observation that the
most difficult part of um many um
operations on objects is removing things
so observing things and adding things is
relatively easy but once you remove
things uh then uh things can get very
complicated and often the best way to
deal with this is to split things into
two parts you lazily Mark something as
being logically removed without doing
the work of actually removing it and you
tell everyone who finds this uh to
pretend it's not
there uh you can't keep doing this
because eventually your object will will
be filled with dead pieces uh so you
have to physically remove it but you can
postpone the the hard work of physical
removing until a time when it's a
convenient uh finally um the last
approach we'll look at is Lock Free
synchronization uh which where we take
the uh atomic parts of the code uh which
uh are normally done with locks and we
move them down into Atomic machine
instructions and uh you can think of
this as uh you know moving the Earth
with a with a lever uh because we often
do a lot of work and then we do one
Atomic machine instruction and that
changes everything and this has uh the
advantage this has the the advantage
that is robust against all kinds of
scheduler anomalies so if you acquire a
lock and then the operating system
decides to uh send you on vacation then
the other threads that are running are
going to have a problem because you've
got the lock and you're not doing
anything and they need to use the
resource uh Lock Free synchronization
doesn't have this problem Lock Free
synchronization is highly robust against
uh these kinds of scheduling issues but
in practice it can often be complicated
and sometimes uh not always but
sometimes it can have a high overhead
so um this the example that we used is a
linked list which is uh fairly simple
but uh highly flexible and useful uh
data
structure uh we're going to use a link
list to implement a set where a set is
just a is a mutable unordered collection
of
items uh each value is either in the set
or not in the set there's no duplicates
uh you can add an item to the set you
can remove remove an item or you can
test for a
membership so on our set implementation
uh there will be some minor variations
but basically we uh keep everything in
sorted order uh we have a sentinel node
with uh uh the minimal value and the
maximal value which are never
manipulated and uh we can use those are
convenient to avoid uh various minor
complications in the
code uh the basic idea is fairly obvious
we add something or remove something uh
by doing the same thing you would do in
a sequential world except that we need
to make sure that it works in a
concurrent
world uh course grain locking uh you
lock the entire thing uh this has the
disadvantage that it's um not
scalable uh the um advantage of course
grain locking is that if you don't
expect much contention then this is what
you should do uh you should uh optimize
the parts of the code that need
optimization and not try to use
high-powered Machinery where you don't
need it and uh particularly uh course
grain locking is
um easy to ad do but you may regret it
later at one point the Solaris operating
system had one lock on the entire
kernel and uh years after it was obvious
that this was a huge performance problem
nobody changed it because everyone was
afraid nobody actually understood how
any how it worked and uh since this was
the flagship product of sun Microsystems
they were extremely reluctant to release
something where they weren't entirely
sure that it worked and this was a drag
on Solaris for many years it was
eventually
fixed uh fine gr locking as I mentioned
before
uh is hard to U hard to do right in many
cases uh the example that we had uh was
a hand overhand locking where instead of
having a single lock on the entire uh
list we would put a lock on each node on
each piece and uh we this would have the
property that you would lock a node lock
its successor release the previous one
and then acquire the next one this is
hand overhand
locking and uh this has the advantage
that it gives you more concurrency
because threads can Traverse the list
simultaneously uh provided they Lo at uh
this we saw you have to be very careful
uh for example uh when you're removing a
node using hand overhand
locking if I'm not going to actually
modify a node there's no reason to lock
it but in fact uh you do need to to do
this and this is actually a fairly
common Pitfall uh when people program up
this kind of um data
structure so um returning to my earlier
theme these algorithms are fairly simple
but proving that that they're correct
can be very subtle and it's easy to fool
yourself into thinking that the
algorithm is correct when in fact uh
there's a hidden um hidden
bug so this is better than course pane
locks uh because threads can Traverse in
parallel but as a practical matter uh
every time you visit a node you have to
acquire and release a lock and we can
make lock acquisition and release fairly
efficient uh but it's still uh not uh
there's still a a cost to it and if we
can engineer our data structures to
minimize the amount of locking then uh
that's really uh that's what we want to
do so the next uh thing that we looked
at was optimistic
synchronization where we assume that
whatever it is we're looking for is not
the target of a concurrent thread so
here we search through the list without
acquiring any
locks and here too the more you know
about it the more frightening this
Prospect is because I haven't said
anything about memory models and other
kind other ways that uh things that can
get you into trouble if you read the
data without locking but the basic idea
is you search without
locking everything you look at can be
changed out from underne benath you at
any time without warning you find the
part of the list that you're interested
in you lock it and then you check to
make sure that uh what you caught is uh
a kind of fish you the kind of fish you
wanted so here for example we uh want to
add C so we Traverse the list without
acquiring any
locks then we lock both of the of the
nodes once we lock the nodes they can't
be modified or deleted and then we add
the
um holding the lock we add the uh item
that we want to add to the list and as I
pointed out you it isn't that simple
because after you lock you have to make
sure that what you locked is what you
thought it was and the conditions that
you want can be a slightly a
subtle uh for example
uh one way you can get into trouble is
you find the nodes that you want you
then you go to sleep someone else comes
along and deletes one of the nodes that
uh you're working
on if you then naively wake up and add
your node then uh you know this doesn't
work and so uh what we have to do is
once you lock the nodes you have to make
sure that the first one is still
reachable and this is a non-local
property basically means you have to
Traverse the list twice and we're still
not done because you can still get into
trouble if somebody else comes along and
adds the node between the two that
you're looking at then when you wake up
acquire the locks and add your node then
uh you also have a problem
yes uh so here here you don't hold the
lock yet I saw the two nodes and I saw
that they were good and I'm about to get
the lock when suddenly poof I go to
sleep the red node comes in locks
changes unlocks and then I wake up and I
don't know that anything has changed and
then I lock the nodes and I assume that
uh that everything is
okay and so uh what that means is that
you have to uh check
um once you get the locks the conditions
that you have to check for uh are um are
kind of a subtle and here we just have
the second thing we have to check for is
that uh the first node still points to
the second node
okay uh evaluation of this well this is
usually a substantial improvement over
hand overhand
locking because we don't have to acquire
as many locks in hand overhand locking
we have to acquire on average we have to
lock half the nodes in the
list uh here we just lock two two nodes
no matter how big the asset uh
is uh when we Traverse the node we don't
acquire any locks
so I can Traverse the node and you can
Traverse the node and we don't interfere
with each other the only time we
interfere is on the specific nodes that
we want to modify and probably uh
they're
different uh this idea of uh having a
weight free traversal where we don't
acquire any locks is going to be
important later on so keep that uh in
your u in the back of your
minds so
um at least on paper uh this has
uh better performance and more
concurrency than the hand overhand
locking but it does have the
disadvantage that you have to Traverse
the list
twice and the contains method has to
acquire locks so traversing the list
twice uh you know may or may not be a
serious problem if list is small then
maybe it's still sitting in your a lot
of it is still sitting in your cach so
it's not too bad uh but you can't count
on it uh the idea that searching the
list uh requires uh means that you have
to acquire locks is
unattractive so uh the optimistic is
effective if scanning twice without
locks is more efficient than scanning
once with
locks you know and is that true it
probably depends on the context uh the
reason we don't like the contains
acquiring locks is most of the time we
expect that's all people will do that is
um most of the time when you build some
kind of a container object you're mostly
searching it
uh rather than adding or removing
things so the next thing that we're
going to look at is the lazy aist
approach so you can think of lazy as
it's very much like optimistic except
we're going to make a few small
changes uh and guarantee that uh we only
have to scan the list once we don't have
to scan it twice the way optimistic did
but we we're still only going to acquire
uh two locks
uh and the contains operation never
needs to lock
anything so uh this is substantially uh
more attractive than any of the lists
that we've shown you before because uh
we don't have to do all of this work to
validate and we can completely eliminate
locks from the most common of our um of
our operations and the key insight as
I've said several times is that the
problem that we have is that we're
moving nodes always causes
trouble and the bugs and pitfalls that
we've seen before usually involve one
thread removing something out from
underneath another thread that's trying
to use it and so if we can make removing
items uh less uh
complicated then everything else will be
much
simpler so uh the idea is that uh remove
is going to scan the list exactly as
before it's going to uh lock the
predecessor of the node that we want to
remove and the node itself just as
before but the actual removal is going
to be split into two steps the first one
is a logical removal where we set a flag
on the data structure which says I'm not
here now even if you see me this flag
says I'm not here ignore
me the Second Step we're going to
actually move the pointers
around and uh uh physically remove the U
item from the list now this sounds like
a uh very simple even minor a change but
it turns out that it's going to have a
pervasive effect on the structure and
performance of the of the
list so uh in picture we're going to add
a flag uh green means that uh you're
present in the list and red means you're
logically deleted and I hope nobody's
red green color
blind I've actually had people complain
about
that so uh logical deltion means we
switch Thea flag from green to red and
physical deletion means we swing the
pointer just as
before so what happens when we uh when
we do
this so all the methods scan
through the when you were when we're
searching for something we just go right
through the list ignoring whether it's
present or not we just follow the uh the
references so that means that we're
we're scanning through nodes that have
been both logically and physically
deleted but uh because we're careful not
to recycle that memory or let the
garbage collector deal with this it's
always the case that even if we're
looking at a node that has been
physically removed from the list if we
keep following the next references we'll
get back onto the list that's an
important uh
invariant so this means for example that
removing a node doesn't slow down uh
scanning because we don't care whe if
whether a node is locked or not we just
scan right through
it we still when we find the node that
we want we still have to acquire two
locks now for
validation uh we can skip the expensive
part remember in validation we had this
problem that we locked a node but we
don't know whether it's still uh there
someone might have already deleted it so
we had to scan from the beginning again
to see whether we could reach that node
here we don't have to do that all we
have to do is we take the predecessor
which we've locked and we check that
it's not marked it's not logically
deleted we check the current node and we
check that it's not logically
deleted then we check that the
predecessor still points to the urrent
node which is exactly what we did before
and now we're
done so all our validation is now local
instead of having to uh reread the
entire list we just look at the two
nodes that we've locked and that's all
that we need now I'm not going to prove
this is a true uh but uh you know it's a
good exercise to uh uh look at that do
it to try
that so uh here's the
um here's a picture so this node uh
scans
through and now uh it locks it finds the
node it's halfway between the two nodes
suddenly the Red Thread shows up it
decides to remove
B and it checks it acquires the lock and
checks well a isn't
marked so it's okay A still points to B
so that's okay and then it does a
logical delete by setting the
flag and then it does a physical delete
by U swinging the
pointer so this is uh again much more
efficient than the removal that we had
before because we don't need to rescan
everything these uh magical Flags uh
save us from having to to do all
that now the green uh node is still
scanning through and it doesn't care you
know so it get gets back so I'm going to
show you uh uh in the slides that'll be
on the web page I'll have a lot more
code examples but I'm not going to go
through all of those here because I want
to cover more material now when I show
you uh this code I want you to look at
it as if it were an impressionist
painting in the sense that don't focus
on any of the details you just drink in
the entire picture and I'll I'll help
you do that by annotating it but don't
worry about any particular uh line of
code so uh what we do is we the validate
uh method says check that the
predecessor is not logically deleted
check that the current node isn't
logically deleted check that one points
to the other and uh return uh the
conjunction of those three conditions so
it's very uh very
simple uh this is the um business end of
the remove method so what it does is you
you valid you acquire the locks and you
validate uh if you found what you're
looking for then do the logical
remove do the physical remove by a
changing the app pointers and then uh um
return true so the uh translating the
pictures to a code here is really quite
uh
straightforward uh now the interesting
thing here is that contains doesn't need
to acquire any
locks uh and this is uh again as I
mentioned a very important practical uh
constraint because it means that every
time you search the asset uh you don't
have to deal with uh expensive locks so
what do we do we start at the
beginning and then uh we search the
range of
keys uh and notice we don't acquire any
locks we just read right through we
don't uh check to see whether it's
locked we don't check to see whether
it's logically deleted we just keep keep
going and then when we find what we're
looking for we say is this the key that
I wanted and is it not logically deleted
if that's true then we found
it now we've done everything without
acquiring any
locks now if I were you I wouldn't um
believe just take my word for this
because there's all kinds of uh uh
subtle things that are going on here and
proving that this is correct is actually
quite quite an
exercise uh there we have a paper where
Tony is one of the co-authors
where we actually do this so uh if Tony
hor thinks that this sort of thing is
worth approving then uh you know we
should all pay attention but it's a very
simple algorithm you know you could
explain the algorithm high school
students uh explaining why it's correct
is so somewhat more
advanced so summary of weight free
contains says that uh you know if you're
not marked the invariant is that if
you're not marked you're in the set if
you're marked or you're not reachable
from the
um from the root then you're not then
you're not in the
set and this is the this invariant is
the basis for approving the correctness
of these these
operations
so we have there's another um kind of
theme here which is that add and remove
acquired locks but contains
doesn't so in the early days of data
structures people moved Heaven and Earth
to try to eliminate all locks from um
from all the operations and ended up
with fairly complicated and somewhat
inefficient uh data structures but if
you say well we really only need to
optimize the really common calls
and if by by leaving locks on the
relatively uncommon calls we can greatly
simplify and speed up the common calls
then that's a good deal so as a
practical matter uh we're Believers in
mixing and matching different
synchronization operations on different
U um on different
operations so uh the good thing about
this is contains doesn't lock in fact
it's weight
free uh if you're uncontended then you
don't need to R
Traverse uh it has the it's still
optimistic and it has the disadvantage
of optimistic operations in that it
doesn't work very well if your optimism
was misplaced so if you have a lot of
contention and it's and your validation
fails every time you lock uh these two
items you turns out that one of them was
deleted or somebody inserted something
in the middle then you have to then all
the work you did so far was wasted you
have to start start over
again uh there's reason to believe
that's quite rare because if that
happened a lot then the level of
contingent would be so high that uh no
uh possible algorithm would work well it
just means your system needs to be
re-engineered to get rid of that level
of
contention so as an engineering um uh
perspective you want to deal with low
and medium contention because if you
have high contention anywhere then you
then you should probably redesign things
so um the optimism if the optimism is
misplaced this doesn't work but this
does have the same problem that all data
structures that use Mutual exclusion
have which is that if you acquire the
lock and you're
delayed then everyone else is
delayed and you could say well How
likely is it that I'm going to be
delayed well you could for example take
a cache Miss after you acquire the lock
and that would delay you for maybe 20 30
uh machine
Cycles uh you could could uh take a you
know there's multiple levels of caches
and uh the lower the level of the cach
miss the more you uh greater the penalty
you could take a page fault and that
would lay you for thousands of
Cycles uh the operating system could
decide to deschedule your thread and run
someone else and that would delay you
for
millions and most of the time you have
no control over
this so uh you know this this is why in
a lot of the um theoretical distributed
computing people talk about processes
crashing and failing so in a real
distributed system processes do crash
you could say well why do we care about
uh crashes and failures in a multicore
it's not the case that I'm going to flip
open my laptop and one of the cores
emits a little plume of smoke and the
others keep
working uh more likely what will happen
is one of my threads will get swapped
out and the delay is so long that we
have to treat it as if they crash
because we're not willing to wait for it
to come back so this is why you hear
talks about talk about crashes and
failures in uh concurrent uh in models
of concurrent
systems although actual crashes and
failures are don't really happen
logically they do and it makes sense to
treat these kinds of unexpected delays
as crashes and failures so this is the
main uh drawback for any kind of
lock-based uh data
structure
so one thread enters the critical
section crashes then everyone's stuck
and so you have to trust the scheduler
doesn't do this but the truth is
schedulers do do this uh there are lots
of proposals uh for example you could
some operating systems let allow you to
tell the um scheduler I'm about to do
something really critical please please
don't deschedule me for another a few
hundred U machine instructions and the
operating system if it decides you're
not abusing this may do this or it may
not uh
so um the thing about uh lock PR data
structures is to guarantee what we call
minimal progress which is that some
thread always makes
progress nobody ever starves or you need
sorry you some threads might starve but
there's never
deadlock so some thread always completes
a method call and you can say what good
is that I'm really worried about
starvation the answer is that most of
the time starvation while a theoretical
possibility doesn't really happen the
scheduler may be in EP but it's not
evil and uh it may uh delay you
um at awkward and inconvenient at times
but it's not really out to get you and
the natural kind of variation
non-determinism means that uh you're
pretty much guaranteed that all threads
will eventually make a progress provided
we can guarantee that some thread always
makes progress so as a practical matter
we often settle for uh minimal progress
instead of requiring that every thread
always make progress under every
circumstance which is typically more
expensive uh those are typically called
weight free data
structures okay so
um what we're going to do is we're going
to um take the same design that we had
before and I'm going to eliminate the
locks and replace it with a compare and
set operation
and uh just as
before uh the um description that I give
you of this may or may not contain
bugs and so while I present this so you
should be thinking uh am I trying am I
trying to do is a hand is quicker than
the eye uh kind of a presentation where
I gloss over uh problems so think about
what could go wrong
uh before we do that I'll review for you
what the compare and Set uh is so
compare and set is it's called a compare
exchange on U Intel
architectures uh it's basically a u a
machine instruction but we can think of
this as a method where there's a
location to memory and we have a an
expected value that we think is there
and we ask tell the hardware to take the
expected value and compare it to the one
that actually there and if they match
replace that with a value that I
specified so it says that if if my
speculation about what's in this memory
is correct then replace it with
something else that I gave
you and return
true and if it turns out that uh the
actual value of that memory was
different from what I expected then
leave it
alone and the return false and all of
this is done
atomically now you can prove uh theorems
that show that this is impossible to
implement in a robust way using uh uh
read and write operations uh very
similar to the flp proof that that
Marcos gave you so this has to be done
in Hardware but the good news is that
every uh processor since 1972 or
something uh provides either this
functionality or or equivalent of
functionality so we have the ability to
do this kind of atomic operation I
should mention that it's stly
expensive because it has to go all the
way through the the memory hierarchy so
this isn't something you want to use
lightly you know typically a comparon
set is um um maybe 100 times slower than
a read or a write because you can't use
all the fancy buffering schemes that
people use for reads and
wres so um here's a way to build a lock
free list so think about this as uh what
we're going to do is instead of
locking the data structures and then
doing operations we're going to do a
comparing set to change the values and
if the comparing set fails then uh we
we'll go back and and try again so as
before we we're going to be lazy and we
have our uh little flag that says
whether the item is present in the uh in
the
set
so here we're going to do logical
removal I'm going to set this
bit so now C is not logically present in
the set although the uh node that holds
C is still physically present in the
list then I'm going to use the compare
and set to to say if that reference is
still pointing to C then turn it around
and point to C's
successor and uh this the comparison and
the change are done automically so I
don't need a
lock so I guess guess the qu um that's
fairly
simple uh does anybody um is anybody
looking at this and feeling a little
creeped
out you have a uh you know a vague sense
of impending doom looking at
this so remember we had this uh problem
um when we did hand overhand locking
what happens if somebody deletes the
node that you're working on
well the same thing can happen
here so here we did we did logical
removal and then before we get around to
doing the physical removal somebody
comes along and adds another node in
between uh c and
e and this will succeed because the
value of the next pointer that it finds
is the one it
expected and so this um this will work
and then the physical removal works the
value of that node is also what we
expected and uh as you can see uh D
which we think is in the node is in the
list isn't there
anymore so
uh here too you need to be uh very
careful about these things the first
thing you think of is almost always 90%
correct and uh if you're really really
clever and experienced then it'll be 99%
correct but but uh you know there's no
substitute for sitting down and actually
working out at least an informal proof
that that uh that this sort of thing is
is correct so the way we're going to
deal with this is we're going to combine
the uh flag and the next pointer into a
single
unit and I represented this symbolically
by removing the black line
here and so this means that when I do
the comparison for the compar and set
i'm comparing two values the value of
the flag and the value of the uh the
pointer so I'm making my Atomic
operation just a little bit
bigger and in fact this is a theme uh
that unfortunately I won't have time to
get into much that people have
discovered that the bigger you make your
Atomic operations the easier life
is and uh if you push that to an extreme
you get uh transactional memory which U
Tim was talking about out but uh for now
we don't have if we had transactional
memory then uh this could be a little
bit simpler but surprisingly not that
much simpler if we want a lot of
concurrency so we combine the bit and
the
pointer and so uh Java actually provides
a u something that does this called an
atomic markable
reference and so what we're going to do
we're going to do the compare and set of
both these values
together so here we have the logical
delete you know the we play the ominous
music because we're leading back up to
the um uh danger
zone and so um so we set that bit and
now when the other thread comes along
and tries to insert the new item its
comparon swap will
fail because even though the reference
the pointer value it found was what it
expected it expected to find a node that
was logically not deleted it expected to
find a green flag not a red flag and
because the comparison fails the compar
and swap will
fail and so this way we will have
skirted
disaster because uh it makes no sense to
append something onto a node that's
logically
deleted and so they the physical removal
however will not will be able to proceed
without uh without problem and so the
know that tried to do this insertion
will then have to go back to the
beginning and try again you can optimize
it so may not have to go all the way to
the very
beginning but that's another story but
uh by putting the bit and the reference
into a single uh uh unit we can avoid
this this
difficulty so again we'll use
um this is a a very useful U this is
such a useful pattern of being able to
put a reference and a bit together that
the Java libraries give you a
prepackaged version of this it allows
you to change the reference and update
the flag uh you can uh set the flag
independently and read each value
independently and so
on so here we are um we're going to
remove uh node
C so uh the first thing you it does is
it changes the uh the pointer it does
the comparing swap to do the physical
remove uh without locks now just to a
check if we have two adjacent removes
that's another uh uh place where we got
into a trouble last time so each one
does The Logical
remove and now both of those values are
are logically gone even though they're
still physically present and when each
one tries to do the compare and swap one
of them will fail and one of those nodes
will be physically removed the other one
will still be
there and so a side effect of this is
that you might encounter logically
deleted nodes that are still there
because our attempt to clean up
failed and the question is uh What uh do
we want to um to do with them well the
easiest thing to do is if you encounter
a logically deleted node um finish the
job and try to physically remove it
interesting thing is you only need to
try once because if you succeed you
removed it if you failed that means that
someone else got in there first and
removed it so it's a relatively
efficient uh
operation
um right so here we have the traversal
remember is lock
free so then we uh discover that there's
a uh deleted node we do our compar and
Swap and physically remove
it um just to show you that uh this is
all uh you know academic uh posturing uh
we'll show you some uh actually at this
but at this time fairly old uh
performance results uh done on sun
machines probably uh maybe 10 years old
by now but the basic idea is um pretty
much the same so here we have what we
would consider a a relatively realistic
uh scenario uh this is the number of
threads uh this these are the number of
operations of per second so higher is uh
is better uh coar grain and fine grain
locks uh basically have a fairly poor
performance and they don't really scale
uh lazy list and Lock Free are roughly
comparable um here Lock Free does
somewhat better than uh than
lazy although the the difference isn't
huge if we um increase the number of um
of
modifications then uh we have roughly
the same uh 50% reads it's roughly the
same
picture uh as the
um here we slice it the other way and as
it contains the ratio goes up you can
see that the course grain and fine grain
locks remain roughly constant and the
lock fre and lazy are roughly
similar okay so these are the uh five
patterns course grain lock fine grain
lock optimistic lazy and lock pre and
what I'll do next is talk about how to
apply these same patterns to more
complicated data
structures so I think I'll I'll start
that and then we'll take a break in
about 10
minutes
so I'm going to talk about concurrent
stacks and cues uh this I chose these
data
structures uh for a couple reasons one
is that q's and their relatives are very
useful uh I understand that a number of
um uh well-known operating systems use
lock free cues for ready cues and
scheduling uh Stacks are interesting uh
because you would think that that Stacks
are inherently sequential that if you
push something outto a stack you pop
something how could you possibly make
that parallel uh what I want to show you
is that surprisingly Stacks can be made
very
parallel uh the greater theme being that
often things that naively appear to be
inherently sequential can be
parallelized if you think about it in
the uh in the right
way so uh once again these are the uh
different ways that we uh will consider
building uh these data
structures
um so a little bit of ter terminology so
you can think of cues and stacks as
having pools of
items so uh represent uh these things as
I don't know what you call at the hotel
they serve these for for breakfast right
next to the idley
uh what's it
called yeah I mean I you know in in uh
the US I tell people they're Donuts but
we want to be culturally appropriate
here so we have a collection of these
things and a q has the property of
course that uh the when you remove
something uh what you get is the uh
first in first out and a stack uh goes
the other way that the last thing that
was put in the pool is uh the
um first one
out uh they can be bounded which means
that they only hold a fixed number of
these items uh that can be useful uh if
you're for example buffering things and
you want to make sure that one process
doesn't get too far ahead of the other
then you can put a limit on how many
things can be buffered between them or
you could have unlimited capacity which
is uh useful in situations where you
don't want to worry about how many
things you have in your
container uh what happens when you try
to uh take something from an empty
stacker Cube but one possibility is you
can block which means that you just wait
until something shows
up uh the other uh place you might block
is if it's already full if it's bounded
and full and you want to put something
in then you could block the alternative
is you could get back an
exception and each of these is useful
under a different context uh so we're
not going to uh look at the cross
product of all of these uh things uh
because that would take too long but
instead uh we'll look at a bounded
blocking lock based uh Q and A bounded
non-blocking uh lock free uh
Q uh for Stacks we'll look at unbounded
non-blocking Lock Free and then we'll
look at the what we call the elimination
backoff algorithm which is a way of
making Stacks highly
concurrent so
um when we have a acue there are a
number of inherent challenges that we
need to face
so uh what we would like is that if we
imagine we have an mq and a
dcer if the Q is big enough in the head
and the tail are far enough apart we
would like them to be able to work
concurrently without without having to
synchronize with each other except POS
possibly in some transient way but uh if
you think about it logically if the ends
of the que are far enough apart then
there's no reason that these two have to
communicate with each other because they
don't influence one
another uh but if the que is empty or
full then some kind of synchronization
is necessary so we want to uh so really
static uh structures aren't going to
work because we don't want to force them
to synchronize on every operation we
they only have to synchronize when
necessary so here's one way to do a
bounded
a so um I'm going
to have one field which is a head which
points to a uh a node that contains an
item we'll use uh a ball instead of
aurus and uh this is a dummy item so the
gry ball is a like a sentinel it doesn't
mean anything but it's there to make the
program structure uh easier to
understand so right now the queue is
empty because the head and the tail both
point to
nothing so now when we want to enq
something
what we'll do is we leave the head
pointing here we have the tail points to
the new item and that's the first item
that is actually in the
CU so um in order to make
synchronization work we'll have one lock
that when you acquire it it locks out
all other DQ
calls so when I acquire that lock an NQ
can might still be able to happen but no
other thread can do a
DQ
and I'll have a symmetric lock that I'll
use to lock out other
nqs so in this way at least in principle
nqs and dqs can go on concurrently
because they're using different distinct
locks now uh we need to tell whether the
Q is full or empty because this is
bounded Q we're going to put a limit on
how many things you're allowed to put
into it and uh you always need to know
whether a que is empty
so I'll put a size counter and in this
example uh we'll say the CU holds a
maximum of eight
items and the thing about this um
counter is it's incremented by NQ
because the number of items is going up
is decremented by a
DQ so here comes an
ner uh which wants to insert this item
in the
Q and so what it does is it lock Lo the
NQ lock because after all it's
enqing it reads the
size and uh I'll tell you what it's
worried that the Q might be full and
I'll tell you in a minute what it does
if it finds that the Q is full but here
it sees that the Q isn't full there are
fewer than eight it items in
there and so uh it doesn't need to um uh
lock
anything so it creates a node to hold it
and it makes two steps uh it puts the
item uh onto this link list and it
updates tail to point directly to the
last
item then it increments it automically
get an increment means automically
increment this
value and the reason uh this has to be
an atomic increment and not just a
regular increment is because there might
be ders running around who are also
modified find this
counter so the lock doesn't protect the
um the counter so one thing uh one
Pitfall of using locks is that the uh
connection between locks and uh the data
is a matter of
convention and you have to be careful
that you understand that
convention then uh you release the lock
and uh go about your
business uh so supp the queue uh was
empty so then the N queer um notifies
the waiting a
ders and I'll tell you how that works in
more detail but what it says is that uh
if if the queue was empty then there may
be ders that were sleeping waiting to uh
get in and so the U ncer will go and
wake them up and say Hey you know come
on out there there's some uh there's
something for
you
uh okay let's roll the film
back and suppose that the nqr uh
acquires the lock and then discovers the
Q is
full so it sees that the size is too
high so then what happens is it will go
to sleep it'll release the lock and go
to sleep and again I'll when we talk
about monitor locks I'll explain in more
detail what what
happens uh T
here comes along and it acquires the DQ
lock which guarantees that no other
thread can do a DQ at the same time it's
not going to inhibit other
nqs so then it reads the goes to the uh
head it goes to the Sentinel it reads
the sentinel's next
field then it reads the value that is
going to
return makes a copy of
it and then what it does is it makes the
prior first node the new
Sentinel why do we do it this way well
when we talk about a lock free version
this will be
handy but uh the convention is that the
very first node in the list is a
sentinel it might have formerly been
meaningful but because it's first it's
um it turns gray and it doesn't mean
anything then decrements the size
releases the DQ
lock if uh the dcer is uh unsuccessful
then it reachs the sentinel's next
field it sees that there's nothing there
and then it goes uh to
sleep now uh you might say well
um what what is all this business about
going to sleep and notifying and so on
so I'm going to take this discussion of
stacks and push it down on the logical
stack and give you a very brief review
of uh monitor locks in conditions uh
this may be already be familiar to some
of you um but I think it's good to make
sure that this is loaded in your brains
for when we uh uh discuss some matters
so um this is all uh of interest to
people who care about Java but the basic
idea is that um when you can't get a
lock there are two things you can do you
can spin which means you sit there and
uh as Lorenzo would say you pester the
lock and you keep asking it uh sometimes
if you expect things to be short then
that makes sense uh if you have no idea
when that lock is going to become free
or when the condition you're interested
in is going to become uh true then it
makes sense to tell the operating system
I can't get anything done why don't you
run someone else for a while and we call
that blocking but we want to have a
mechanism where if the condition you're
waiting for becomes true then someone
will will wake you
up and that's what uh we want to um to
talk about and typically uh this is uh
all rolled up in in uh uh
locks so you can acquire a lock you can
release a lock or you can wait on a
condition associated with
lock so in uh in Java uh there's a call
to create a a lock there's a call to
release a
lock uh there are calls that say get me
the lock but don't try too hard uh you
know if I can't get the lock immediately
then return false so but it can't get
lock within a certain amount of time
return
false and the one that we care about now
is uh that we want to create a condition
to wait on so what is a
condition is a
uh when you call a wait that says
release the lock and wait on the release
the lock associated with this condition
and wait until it becomes
true signal says wake up one thread
that's waiting on this condition signal
law says wake up every thread that's
waiting on this condition
so a weight releases the a lock
associated with the condition sleeps
that is it gives up the processor at
some point it awakens that is it resumes
running and reacquires lock and
returns so you execute down here you're
holding the lock you say
await while you're inside here you could
release the lock and things can change
but when you return from this call you
have the lock
again signal again awakens uh one
waiting thread which will reacquire the
lock signal all uh wakes them all
up
um let me give you a kind of a
figurative view of how this works so
here we have uh the uh the lock this is
the critical section this is the code in
this case we have an item that's sitting
inside the que you can think of this as
a room where the thread comes in and
either deposits an item or removes the
item this is the waiting room where you
hang out if uh whatever it is that you
want can't what if your need current
need cannot be
satisfied so thread comes in it acquires
the lock and it goes into the critical
section it consumes the item releases
the lock and goes on its way so this is
uh normally what uh what
happens now it comes back again for more
uh it want to do a DQ it acquires the
lock it goes in the critical section and
it sees oh it's empty and now what well
you might say well okay all all I need
to do is just sit around and wait for
something to show
up any reason not to do
that because because you're holding the
lock you know it's like a you know
2-year-old uh you know locks the door
and goes goes in the back bathroom locks
the door be and then falls asleep you
know nobody can get in there so even if
uh you know tons of threads want to uh
deposit an item uh they won't get in
okay so then it calls the
weight which we just talked about and
that releases the lock and moves the
thread into the waiting room where it
sleeps so now this thread is not using
up any resources it's sitting on some
link list in the uh uh bowels of the
operating system waiting to be to be
awoken
kind of like that Prometheus
movie so another F comes
along it acquires a lock and it meets a
similar
fate so it calls a wait and now it's
sitting in the waiting room and they're
both
asleeping finally an ener comes along
with an item to uh deposit so it
acquires the lock goes in deposits the
item and it calls signal all the wake up
everyone
so they wake up now they can't do
anything until the uh orange thread
releases the lock but after it releases
the lock they've been woken up now the
specification you know these
specifications are all written very
carefully by lawyers and there's no
guarantee on when actually you wake up
at some point after signal is called
some point after the lock is released
then you wake
up and the Red Thread wakes up first
and it acquires the
lock now notice that uh when you wake up
and reacquire the lock there's no
guarantee that there's anything there so
somebody could have gotten in there and
consumed that item
first so uh the Red Thread though is
lucky it gets what it wants the Green
thread wakes
up it acquires the lock it enters and uh
finds oh it's still
empty so then it has to back to the
waiting it sort of skulks back to the
waiting room goes back to sleep and
waits for uh for better
days so uh this is uh Java provides a
synchronized method which uh actually uh
does all of this with um you know
slightly different
keywords but I'm I'm going to skip that
since Java isn't um the point of this
but the last thing I want to do before
we do a break is to point out yet
another
Pitfall so uh
I don't want to give you the the
impression that all of this is easy so
here we have a situation where uh
thinking back on the last execution
where we woke up two threads and there
was only one uh thread that um could um
acquire something say well instead of
waking up everyone why do we just wake
up one thread you know that seems more
economical so
here same thing orange locks deposits
its item
uh the CQ is empty so it signals and it
only wakes up one
thread uh now a yellow thread comes
along and before the Red Thread can wake
up the yellow thread comes in deposits
something requires a
lock and it says well the Q is not empty
so there's no need to
signal right because uh the only reason
that threads would be sleeping is
because there wasn't anything to consume
if I'm the first one to put something
into in then there might be sleeping
threads but if I come along and uh
there's already an item there then
there's no reason to wake anyone
up so it uh unlocks and and goes away
the Red Thread wakes
up it comes along it consumes its item
it goes on its way and now there's
nobody left to wake up wake up the green
thread because it's waking up only one
thread was a false economy
because uh the way things were set up
that green thread is going to wait
forever even though it there is
something for it to
do and so um what's wrong here is that
uh we didn't we were too parsimonious
with our
wakeups and so uh what I advise my
students is always use signal all and
notify all even if you think you can
prove it's unnecessary because sooner or
later somebody's going to come along and
change your code and they won't think
about it and uh uh lost wakeup bugs are
very hard to find because nothing
happens so it's a sin of omission rather
than a sin of
commission and uh what'll happen is
you're um you'll have a thread that
Waits forever with nothing to do and it
can take a long time before you notice
this okay let's take a break and come
back in five minutes okay so we can um
do a kind of an engineering uh review so
the NQ and DQ methods don't share locks
so that means mqs and dqs can go on in
parallel but they do share an atomic
make a
counter uh which is uh access by every
method call and you could say well you
know we we've removed one
synchronization bottleneck only to
encounter another one and so I'll I'll
give you just a brief uh description of
what you can do to alleviate this this
this is more Amusement than anything
else uh so the notice that the counter
the NQ method only increments the
counter and the only thing it doesn't
care what the value is it only wants to
know whether it's whether the que is
already full symmetrically the DQ method
only decrements the counter and so it no
only cares whether the value is zero uh
any intermediate value is of no U of no
interest so what we can do is we can
split the counter into two pieces uh
which we'll call the NQ size and the DQ
size and then we'll have the NQ or
increment one counter the DQ or uh
decrements the other counter when the
ncer runs out of room then we stop and
lock both of them and transfer the the
credits from one side to the other and
that way we can greatly reduce the
amount of um locking and synchronization
that that we have to do and depending on
your uh taste this is either a vile hack
or an elegant solution to a
synchronization problem and uh you can
take your
choice okay so let's make this uh lock
free uh that is we're going to replace
the locks with a comparan swap so as
before we'll set everything up uh pretty
much the way it was before with the head
and the tail and the Sentinel and
remember the compare and swap operation
uh allows us to automically change a
field it says if this field is what we
expect then set it to the value that uh
that I give you and so here we have an
ner that comes in and it uh creates a
node to hold uh the uh
item and then it does a uh logical NQ
which is a compar and swap to swing this
pointer and so now we're in a kind of a
curious halfway State because the item
is reachable from the head but the tail
is off by
one and uh because I'm assuming we don't
have transactional memory uh we can't
change the head and the tail
simultaneously so we have to split this
operation up into two Atomic steps so
then we do the physical NQ where we
we'll do a compare and swap to was set
the tail to point to the uh the the tail
field to point to the new and and actual
tail now let me emphasize that these two
steps are in atomic and so now we have
to be prepared whenever we look at the
tail to find either that it's good in
points to the tail or it's off by one
and it's looking uh not at the last node
but at the uh node before the last
node and so uh what do you do if you
find a trailing a tail well it's it's
like the um um logical delete that we
saw before uh probably the next thing
the best thing to do is to stop and fix
it and then resume and this guarantees
that the tail never Falls very far
behind in fact it never Falls more than
one away from from the actual
tail
uh what happens when if your uh
comparing swap fails meaning I did a I
uh did a compare and Swap and behold
what I find is different from what I Ed
so if you're doing a logical enq that
means that you're in trouble that means
that somebody else enced something or or
deced something and the best thing to do
is to just give up and start over again
if you're cleaning up on behalf of
yourself or someone else then actually
that's okay because it just means that
somebody else did the clean up before
you and then you can uh
proceed uh what does a dcer do well the
dcer reads the value that it wants to to
a
DQ and then it does a compare and swap
to make the first node the new
Sentinel so uh this is uh one reason why
having a sentinel is a good idea because
if we didn't have that Sentinel this
would be much much harder but because we
have the convention that the physically
first node contains a meaningless value
uh we can uh we can do
this so
um the next thing we want to say is well
you know when we're putting things into
the queue we allocate a um a list entry
to hold it when we remove something we
remove a list entry and what do we do
with these with these things uh so we
have an ecological problem in that we're
allocating all these list elements and
uh only using them once now in Java of
course where there's garbage collection
this isn't much of a problem because
we'll let the garbage collector deal
with it but uh what if we're writing in
a language that doesn't have a garbage
collector or what if we don't want to
use the garbage collector because we
think we can do it more efficiently so
here for example the DQ or DQ
something and it should be able to
recycle that
node now uh we have to be uh careful
here so let's say that each thread has a
free list of unq of unused a
nodes uh local stuff is better anything
we can do without synchronization is
better so everybody keeps their own free
list and you can allocate and free from
your own uh list
and uh if you run out of things then
we'll uh we have some extraordinary way
of allocating a new storage but uh what
we would like is that everybody
allocates and frees from their own list
now um this sounds like a very simple
idea but it's fraught with
danger and so uh here is a another way
that you can get into a trouble so here
I have a node that is about to do a
compare and swap so this is the uh value
it wants to change this is the value it
wants to point to this is the head and
tail part of the Q and this is the
threads fre
pool so uh what it wants to do is it
wants to
um it's in the middle of a DQ and it
wants to take this reference and set it
over
here so it wants to redirect the head
from the gray node to the red
node but before it does that it falls
asleep and takes a
nap now what happens is all kinds of
other threads come along and they do
lots of
dqs and uh move these items into the
free pool because theyve both been dced
while this thread is off on
vacation and currently this is what the
queue looks like it's empty this is a um
a sentinel node and uh while this thread
is still
sleeping uh these nodes are uh are
reused and so now what happens is that
one of the nodes that uh was in the free
pool is placed back in the
que uh holding a different item this
time but the address is the
same and now the thread wakes up and
says oh where was I oh yes I was about
to do a compare and
Swap and it does a compare and Swap and
in fact it succeeds because the pointer
value that it
presents uh is actually the one that it
expected what it doesn't know is that
the meaning of the data that it points
to has changed because we
recycled uh the uh uh the data the
physical location is the same as what it
expected but the contents have changed
unexpectedly and so now the Q is a
complete mess because they had points
into the free pool and and and so on so
this ecologically responsible green idea
which seemed so virtuous turned out like
so many ideas of the kind to will lead
only to more
trouble so uh what went
wrong uh so uh at the begin this is
called the ABA problem and uh you know
you see this a lot in concurrent data
structures uh the head reference here as
value a and the thread reads value a
later on the the head reference has
value B and node a is freed and while
read its meaning changes its contents
change and then uh the um it's set back
to a and then compar and swap uh
succeeds because the references match
even though uh the um this note has been
reincarnated to have a different meaning
and this is a common fitall if you're
using compar and swap combination of
compar and Swap and memory
management uh so why is this well this
happens with compare and Swap and uh you
know this is built into the
architectures there's another uh roughly
equivalent thing called load Link store
conditional uh that the power PC
provides that doesn't have this problem
uh which makes your life easier but uh
since most of us are doomed to use Intel
machines we have to worry about compar
and
swap so uh one solution is you could tag
each pointer with a counter and every
time you recycle that data you increment
the counter so the pair of counter and
reference are unique even if the
reference is the
same and uh you can say well uh what
happens uh if the counter overflows well
like every overflow problem uh maybe uh
it won't overflow in your lifetime you
don't have to worry about it maybe it
will uh depends on your on the
context uh this is a common enough
pattern that again Java provides
something called the atomic stamped
reference class toh to solve this
problem
uh if you want to implement this in
language other than a Java then the
usual ways you can take a word and
usually the low order bits on an address
aren't used and you can use that as a as
a
counter and uh uh you can't do that in
garbage collected languages because they
don't like it when you um play games
with your
pointers um okay so let's um switch our
attention from qes to
Stacks so a stack is just like a q
except uh we move uh the um
uh we call the operations push and pop
and the pop uh push and pop operate on
the same ends of the um uh object
instead of at the at different ends so
here's a very simple lock free stack so
we have a uh pointer to the top of the
stack we have a uh Sentinel Sentinel
node just as before so when I want to
push I create a new node I set the uh
reference to point to the the um
Sentinel and now I do a compare and
Swap and now uh my node is at the
top so I do can do another
push now I want to do a pop what I do is
I read the value that I want to pop and
I do a compare and swap to push it
back so this is very simple uh if we
don't do memory recycling we don't need
to worry about ABA if we do then we can
solve it with uh you know by attaching
counters and so
on uh what's good about this is there's
no
locking but the
problem well again uh if we don't have
garbage collection then you have to
watch out for ABA but the problem is
that everybody who wants to operate on
the a stack whether they want to push or
pop or anything else they've got to do a
compare and swap on the same memory
location and uh this is uh going to be a
big what's called a hot spot because
it's going to bounce around a caches all
over the place so you know if if if I'm
pushing and um you're popping then it's
going to bounce back and forth between
our caches and we'll take a cach miss
each time we touch it and the result
will be uh will be Dreadful and in any
case there's no parallelism in the sense
that if I want to do a push and someone
else wants to do a push and we Collide
then it's kind of like one of those old
fashion westerns you know one lives and
the other one dies uh you know it's a
showdown and uh there's no way that both
of them can make progress at the same
time so the operations are effectively
serialized so there's really no
concurrency going on here even the
pushes and the pops uh have no
concurrency and you might say well this
is the way that it was faded to be
because how can you possibly get uh
concurrency out of a stack where
everything happens all at once in the
same
place
so what I'm going to tell you is how to
take contention and turn it into
parallelism so this is going to have the
U paradoxical effect that the more
contention you have the more parallelism
you have which is probably not what you
expecting so um often in um in many
situations when you have contention one
way to to alleviated is what's called
exponential back off so you're standing
at a party and a group of people and
several people start talking at once so
what you do typically is you fall silent
you wait for a random duration and try
again and if the durations are
sufficiently spread out then everybody
gets to talk in a turn and uh we don't
have to worry about contention so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
this exponential backoff idea and change
it in some interesting ways so here is
the basic idea of uh we have a
linearizable stack here we have a thread
that wants to do a push and a thread
that wants to do a
pop so here the push
happens and now the pop
happens and uh what do we
notice it's the same at the beginning at
the end so if the the push and the pop
kind of cancel each other
out so after an equal number of pushes
and Pops the sack is the same so um this
is a little bit like uh you know if you
want to sell your house then uh you have
to pay money to a real estate agent but
if you know that a friend of yours wants
to buy a house then you can do the sale
directly without going through the real
estate
agent so what we can do is we'll put an
intermediate level in here which we'll
call the elimination
array and the idea is that uh when the
pushing thread wants to push it picks a
slot at random and it puts its value
there
and the popping thre when it comes along
it picks a slot at random and it checks
is there something there for
me and if they happen to collide then
what happens is that the
push and the and the pop can ex exchange
their value without ever visiting the
array without ever having to do a
compare and swap on the same
location so they can bypass all of the
synchronization uh uh
necessary and then they continue and uh
this the actual stack is left
undisturbed so uh there's no need to
access the stack and everyone is is
happy now suppose they're less
fortunate and uh they don't meet up then
after a while they can uh try something
and say they can try this it's not
working out then uh they can go on to
the stack so this is kind of a you try
once to see whether you can do
elimination and if it succeeds then uh
you uh you run off and don't bother with
any synchronization if it fails then you
go ahead and do the compare and swap uh
part as
before and so uh the
um the basic idea is that you can go to
the lock free stack and try it once try
a compare and swap if it succeeds you're
done if it fails that means that there's
contention and if there's contention
then it makes sense
to instead of backing off what what you
might do is you might back off and say
well I'm going to wait till the traffic
clears out and try again but instead of
doing that while you're waiting go to
the elimination array pick a random slot
and try to have a rendevu with someone
else and you're no worse off than you
would have been doing the um uh doing
the back off because you wouldn't have
been doing anything else anyway and so
this gives you a chance to Short Circuit
all the
synchronization and it has the property
that the higher the contention the light
higher the probability you'll meet
someone so in this case we turn
contention into uh into concurrency here
so uh the way this works is we'll uh we
try the compar and swap if it fails we
back
off uh there are a lot of parameters
here you can pick a random range and
maximum weight type depending on the
amount of contention so if you keep
encountering a contention so if you hang
out in the array for a while and uh
nothing happens you try again and
there's still contention then maybe you
want to narrow the arrange to increase
your
probability uh but if there's uh if
there's contention on this structure
then maybe you want to use more
slots and an interesting open question
is how to pick the uh waiting time and
the ass
size uh I've seen proposals for using
machine learning to uh uh look at
similar kinds of problems so uh you know
this you know doing some kind of
intelligent uh learning on this uh kind
of problem would could be interesting
yeah uh it if I I'll tell you to say if
one push and one pop connect the pushes
and Pops have to be one to one so you
have to make sure that uh the if if I
push something then it isn't pop twice
yeah that that that's a very good
question and I'll answer that the key is
you remember I spent the very beginning
talking about linearizability
and so if you have two pushes that
happen close enough together then they
overlap and the fact that they one might
physically in the implementation happen
get to the array first doesn't matter
because linearizability says that if
they overlap you can order them any way
you want so you know this is why I spent
all the time on linearizability at the
beginning is because once we realize
that that's our correctness condition we
have a lot of freedom to do small
Maneuvers and and
Things Push and
go
then he he won't he won't push until he
knows that it's been consumed if he's in
if he's in the buffer I have in the
longer version I have the code where we
go through that in in in more detail but
uh when I I'll talk about exchangers
next and and explain why that can't
can't happen but but it's a good uh it's
a good
point so you know we can choose larger
ranges and uh longer times and figuring
out what the right values for these
things are is uh I think an interesting
open research question you know right
now uh every time somebody wants to show
that this works well they experiment a
little bit find the optimal values and
show how great it is and if you have an
alternative then you pick less than
optimal values and show how much better
your alternative
is so how do we know this is
linearizable so there's an excellent
question uh you know why should we
believe why should you believe me you
know because this these things are
subtle enough that I could probably
stand up here and and present totally
bogus algorithm and as long as I looked
everyone in the eye and uh you know you
would believe me so I'm let me outline
how you would argue that this happens so
the basic idea is that um I think the uh
un linearized or rather without
elimination the one that just uses
compare and swap that's pretty clearly
linearizable because it's just the order
of the compare of the compar and swaps
so if the calls aren't eliminated we
just rely on that so what happens is if
we eliminate the calls we're going to
linearize each pop immediately after the
matching
push and uh the combination I claim is a
linearizable
stack so it looks something like this
so we look at the UN uneliminated
operations and we can linearize those in
the order of the comparon
swaps so that's okay so now we're going
to look at the eliminated operations so
here's a push and here's a pop and let's
say that they rondu in the elimination
array they never make it to the stack so
uh what I'll do is I'll find the point
where they
Collide the point where the pop thread
discovers that there's an item uh
waiting for it in the
array and so I'm going to
um schedule the the push happen I'm
going the pop happens here when the
popping thread consumes it so I'm going
to say well I'm going to put the push
pushing thread immediately before it
which I can do because it's uh clearly
the push doesn't return until it knows
that uh the um its value has been
consumed and I have all this freedom to
uh U to pick a a linearization
point and this is why uh we care about
linearizability because we need to be
able to do these kinds of arguments to
tell to to detect whether our uh
algorithm is correct or
not and this is that that's the basic
argument so the back off
um is good for two reasons one is
because we back off in the array that
cuts down the contention on the compare
and
swap so that says that if you fail to uh
connect with someone on the elimination
array and you have to do the compar and
swap you're better off because we've
eliminated uh the uh at least some
contention for this so even if you don't
uh ride the Metro uh and you drive a car
you're better off if other people ride
the Metro because there's more room on
the road for
you and elimination on the array cuts
down the number of threads accessing the
lock for pre stack and as I mentioned
the higher the contention the higher the
probability you'll be able to combine
and use this shortcut so this is a case
where uh
contention we're we're turning uh
something bad namely namely contention
into something good namely
concurrency so um how do we implement
this well we need something called an
exchanger which is a way of um
automically making sure that uh to that
that the pushing thread and the popping
thread uh both agree that um they've
handed over the item from the pushing
thread to the popping
thread uh what
um I think I'll uh
I'll skip some of this um Java stuff but
an exchanger has basically three steps
think of it as a box where I I I have a
box I put something into it and then I
wait and someone else comes along and
they automically replace my item with
their item and then they go up out their
way and then we both uh are happy with
what we have it's a little bit similar
to to what Lorenzo was talking about
except we're not worried about u a
Byzantine or rational
processes uh the other thing that can
happen is I can go out there and put
something in the box and wait for
someone to show up and they don't show
up so that point I I can withdraw my
offer and you need to be careful that I
don't try to withdraw my offer at the
exact same time when someone else tries
to accept
it so the um status of an exchanger
could be that the box is
empty it could be that one thread has
put its item in the box and is waiting
for someone else to come along and do
the exchange
uh or it could be that uh I I want to
use the box but two other threads are
using it already so I
can't uh so this is the uh exchanger
takes so I want to do an exchange I give
the item and I give it a timeout because
I'm not willing to wait
forever uh the um so what I'll do is
I'll Loop until uh
timeout uh
I'll I'll
uh I think I'll just stick with the with
the picture so here is the exchanger
thread comes
along it does a compare and Swap and
sets the state to
waiting so this says that the Red Thread
has deposited the red
item and is waiting for U now this item
could either if red is pushing then
that's a real item if red is popping
then this is a dummy item know is it's
something that just says that I I want
to
pop a
value so it waits for a
while and then finally maybe another
thread shows
up so what that thread does is it tries
to exchange the item and set the status
to
busy so using a compare and swap it has
to be able to uh change both Fields uh
automically it
exchanges and now it has the red item
and the blue item is waiting and then at
some point red uh notices that something
is there and so it consumes the item and
sets the value to to
empty so that's that's basically how how
the exchanger
Works
um I'm going to skip through the uh
actual code
here
yes uh yeah so when you time out then
you have to do a
um a compare and
Swap
and see if I can find
that you know maybe I won't look for it
but but basically you try to do a compar
and swap that fails then that can only
fail because somebody came along and
actually did the exchange at the last
minute so every all the state changes
have to be done automically using using
compare and swap uh again with
transactional memory this would be a lot
simpler because a lot of this depends on
the fact that uh there's only one word
can be uh changed
automically but even transactional
memory wouldn't make this too much
simpler because the logic is the same in
in any
case
okay so then uh how how do we so now
that now that you've seen how do use the
elimination array I can show you the
code for um uh this visit method visits
the elimination array for fixed uh range
uh you pick a random array
entry uh you either exchange the value
or you timeout and the timeout is uh
done as a
um
uh as an
exception so push uh tries to push if it
fails you back off visit the elimination
array and and so
on uh pop leaves if you do the
exchange and uh you get back a the wrong
kind of um a node so if I'm pushing and
I get back a pushing a node then I have
to go back and do it
again and so on okay so um
here is the um takeaway for this part of
the the lecture so we saw uh lock based
and Lock Free implementations of cues
and stacks uh Lock Free cues are
actually fairly widely used in all kinds
of
um uh of applications they're often used
for rqes and operating systems the other
place where I was surprised to find the
lock qes are very um uh popular is in
music so if you're if you're designing a
codc something that transforms music
from One format to another it has to
respond in basically in real time and uh
locks introduce too much a Jitter so if
you go to um Google Groups and you look
up a lock based queue most of the hits
you'll get will be on alt music uh this
that and the other thing so anything
where you need to sort of consume things
in uh in real time uh Lock Free cues are
very popular and in fact the particular
lock prq that we did here which is due
to um Michael Scott and mugged Michael
is the one that most of them
use uh we also look at uh Lock Free
Stacks uh you can argue about whether
Stacks are you know really lie at the
heart of modern uh uh computer industry
but uh we we did that because this is
this elimination principle is useful in
a lot of other contexts but mostly I
wanted to impress on you the fact that
something that looks like it's totally
sequential isn't necessarily uh going to
be
sequential so I guess in the 15 minutes
remaining I'm going to
um do one
last very quick
uh thing which is uh one way to do
concurrent
counting so I'm I'm going to be very
um quick here but imagine that I want to
implement a container you know like a
sacker q except I don't really care much
about the order in which things are
added and
removed and so what I could do is I
could put a lock on the whole thing but
that lock is um becomes a hot spot so
what I could do
instead uh was I could say well um let's
have a shared
counter where the ner takes a
uh takes a takes a value from the
counter dcer takes a value from the
counter and all the NQ are share a
counter and all the DQ are share a
counter and we won't I won't worry about
uh you know wraparound and things like
that for for
here but this means that only the
counters are sequential so instead of
having one hotspot I now have two and
having two hotpots is better than having
one hotspot of course and so uh shared
counter says that the threads come come
in and they they ask for counter values
and uh they get uh they get counters
they get values and the first thing we
say is well we want no
duplication so we want to make sure that
uh the same value wasn't handed out
twice and there's no
gaps but we don't care whether it's
linearizable it turns
out so what we want to do is want to
build a shared counter with low memory
contention and lots of
parallelism so let me give you um here's
a very simple gadget called a
balancer so
um you know really this is a shared
memory data structure but let's think
about it as if it were a some kind of a
network so we have two wires coming in
two wires coming out and we have a very
simple switch which points to one of the
output wires and a
token which you can think of as a
message comes in it visits the balancer
It Goes Through the Wire pointed to by
the arrow and it flips
the switch to the to the next
Arrow and then another token comes in it
does the the
same and uh this keeps uh keeps
going and what's interesting here is the
uh you have the distribution of input
tokens Can Be arbitrary but the output
is
balanced and we'll Define a quiescent
state to be one where all the tokens in
the network have gone
through so um let's build a network of
these things so we'll call this a
smoothing Network because when the
tokens go
through the number of tokens uh that
come out on the output wires uh differ
by at most
one we'll call it a counting
network if they all the excess tokens
are pushed up to the top wires so the
output has was called the step
property and the reason you know
counting networks count is that uh I can
take a bunch of counters implemented any
way you want put a counting Network in
front of them and it does a kind of a
load balancing so each counter here
counts by
four but each counter uh has one quarter
the load that it had before and in here
there's no single hotspot so all of the
synchronization is smeared out over the
memory
and uh the step property if you think
about it guarantees that the values that
are coming out uh that every value is
accounted for in aescent
state I'll skip some of the subtleties
so this is good for counting the number
of networks low contention uh High
throughput uh practical networks are
basically log squar to n where n is the
number of input wires so
um this is what a accounting
Network looks
like in practice when you come out you
take each value this is a sequential
execution where the tokens go through
one at a a time uh this is has a
particular structure called the bonic
accounting Network where K is the number
of input wires and it has the property
that if they go through concurrently is
a equivalent to a sequential
execution uh it's not linearizable so
here's an example of a non linearizable
execution so this thread or this token
goes through it falls asleep in the
middle another token comes
in it falls asleep partway through the
red token comes
in and it takes
two because the value zero and one would
have been taken by these um uh tokens
that are asleep and if I wake them up
and send them through now now they'll
take a zero and one and so the counting
is okay but now the yellow token comes
in and it takes zero which is not
linearizable because yellow started
before
uh yellow started after red finished so
red should have taken an earlier value
but that's not what what happened so
these things are not linearizable but
they do um it's what we call quiescently
consistent meaning that if you push all
the to if you drain all the token out of
the network then all the values are
taken so how do you build these things
well there's a an inductive structure so
we take two half-size bonic networks we
link them up to a merger
network uh this is what the bonic for
looks like this this is a half siize
bonic Network consisting of a single
node this is a half sizee consisting of
a single node and that's the merg your
Ford
network uh this is what the bonic a
looks like here we have uh two copies of
the a four wide this is the uh merger
network uh we can unfold this so we here
we have mer and in fact it's mergers all
the way
down once we unfold it uh this is the
adep basically a log Square
DEC uh how do we know this works well
let's uh uh argue by by induction so
single balancer has the step property by
definition
um what we want to show for the um proof
is that if if a kwire bonic network has
a step property so does a 2K uh uh merge
value uh by induction hypothesis each of
the half-sized networks have the step
property we feed it into the merger
Network and what we need to prove is
that uh the output has theep property uh
the merger network is also recursively
defined we take two half siiz mergers
and we add one more layer by the way if
you could figure out how to get rid of
that layer you would have a log depth
network uh which is uh it's known that
log depth networks exist but nobody's
ever actually constructed one so that
would be uh you know you could get a u a
girdle prize if you could prove
that this is what it looks like when you
actually lay it out you know the uh the
uh schematic is uh kind of conceptual
simplification so uh basically what we
do point out if sequence has a step
proper so is it's even subsequence and
it's odd
subsequence and so if we take two uh of
these things and we kind of we take the
even even subsequence and odd and odd
and even subsequence and put them here
we now have
four
uh uh outputs with the with step
property uh they differ by most
one so here the outputs have the step
property we mix it we mix them up put
them through the merger
Network and they uh we end up with um
each half-size merger network works by
the induction hypothesis so we have
outputs here that uh have the step
property and they differ by most one but
it could be that the extra one is on the
wrong is on the wrong side so here for
example we want this to be upstairs so
we put one more level of uh things and
that moves everything
up so I realize this is much too fast to
um follow in a detail but I just wanted
to show you that this is something else
uh that uh that you can
do uh you there's something called a
periodic counting Network which has a
completely different structure it does
the same thing and that also has a nice
recursive structure uh schematically it
uh looks like this and what we do is we
can take a logarithmic number of these
things and that's accounting
Network so uh this has the advantage
that unlike the other one which was kind
of
which was um had more structure here we
have to take the same thing and we just
repeat it certain number of times and
you can prove that that's a accounting
Network as
well um let's
see I think there you can prove that if
um a network is a county network if the
tokens go through one at a time then
it's a county network if they go through
concurrently so that simplifies
approving
things
uh
they actually perform quite well in
practice uh the way to understand it is
that uh you think of the tokens going
through as something like oil in a
pipeline if you have if you have if the
network is too big and you have not
enough tokens then you have bubbles if
it's saturated then you have optimal
throughput if you have too many tokens
then you start getting contention on the
uh different
switches and so Optimal Performance uh
the number of tokens is roughly W log W
and experimentally uh that um is has
been
confirmed okay
um well there's more other related data
structures but I won't go into that I
just want to alert you that there's a
whole field of data structures that have
this kind of flavor and
um this is something where there was a
lot of work on this in the 9s it was
kind of quiet for a while and now it's
picking up again because these things
work well for Numa architectures and uh
you can also do this in in a distributed
way in a lot of uh kind of interesting
um ways that reflect uh the realities of
emerging uh computer architectures okay
so in conclusion um what I wanted to do
was say emphasize first off that your
correctness condition matters uh the
fact that we can get away with all of
these wild tricks is excused by the fact
that we picked linearizability as our
correctness condition uh if we hadn't
been clear about the what a correctness
condition was then it would not have
been obvious whether all of these fancy
tricks that we do were correct or not uh
we wouldn't know whether it was
acceptable to do all of these things but
because we started out with a good
theoretical Foundation we know that we
can get away with all these practical
kinds of Tricks uh there's a lot of
other data structures hashtables
um and so on uh you can you know some of
those are covered in the book uh some of
them are still research areas so if you
can do a nice really scalable priority
queue then that would certainly be a
publishable result uh scalable balance
trees are are hard because rebalancing
is a global operation and doing that
concurrently with other operations is
something that's still not well
understood so there are a lot of open
questions in this area so it's not all
settled um um material no matter how um
much it looks like it's it's it's all
been done so I encourage you to go off
and look in this area and if you have
any questions I'm here
thanks